keeping it real reals how we keep it get
ready
[Music]
greetings of peace how are you guys
doing you know martin luther king
said that the greatest danger for
humanity
is sincere ignorance and conscientious
stupidity
let's go to this clip i'll be right back
and we should call it radical islam that
is what it is
i feel like it's a breath of fresh air
that we're gonna have a president is
quite frankly not scared to say it for
once radical islam
except radical islam it's all safe
together islamophobia machine is
affecting even our good friends
at the alex jones show
hopefully we can have the invite my
brother on dr sabile
let's start with the radical islam
what's going on how do you respond to
that
assalamu alaikum my dear muslims
greeting of peace
you know when i watched that clip
brother eddie i was pretty sad that
they are attaching the word radical to
the word islam
which is a misnomer it's very important
for
us to educate them in sharing with them
that there is only one islam there is no
such thing as
radical islam or progressive islam or
liberal islam
there is only one islam so if they are
going to use the word
radical with the word islam just because
a muslim may have done something wrong
that means just to be fair it should be
good that they can also they should also
use the word radical
when a christian in the name of
christianity commits a crime
for example how many times have we seen
the word radical christianity used
when the army of the lord commits crimes
in the name of christianity
or when jim jones when he had his cult
commit suicide 800 people
in guyana or how many times we have used
the word radical christianity
when andre brevik he massacred 78 people
in norway about three months ago about
three years ago
how about the planned parenthood clinic
when the person in the name of god
christianity
went and shot about four or five people
about kkk
so all of them they represent
christianity or in the name of
christianity they have committed this
heinous acts
but are we using the word radical
christianity we are not
so just to be fair since we don't want
to use the word radical christianity
because we know that it is not
christianity that motivates those people
it is their human fallible nature they
are mental they have mental problems
and other reasons in the same way just
to be fair
we should not use the word radical islam
we can say that a radical person may
have done it but definitely
not islam but why stop at
you know the word radical islam if you
want to use radical
let's use it for radical christianity
judaism hinduism
but let's not let's not stop up there
why not a radical white when a white
person does something wrong
or a radical white race radical black
race
a radical america radical saudi arabia
there is no stopping when we are using
these labels
so the best thing to do is not use the
word radical islam radical christianity
just say that yes a radical act was done
by a person
and we as humans we should all condemn
that act
doesn't matter who makes the act who
commits the act
what ideology he's doing it for what
weapon he's using who he's killing or
she's killing
we as humans we condemn all these acts
and obviously islam condemns it you know
in chapter 5 of the quran verse number
32 it says
that taking the life of one innocent
person is like taking the life
of all of humanity so that is what islam
is a faith of peace
is not radical a person can be radical
but islam is
peace it's not radical helping to remove
the
ignorance sincere ignorance people
falling victim
to many of the false
narratives that are perpetuated out
there let's go to another part of this
clip in the essence of removing some of
the ignorance
and god willing if they'd invite you on
the alex jones show
would you come on dr sebio inshallah i
would be there
god willing he'll be there so let's go
to the next clip let's look at the list
of islamic terror attacks in 2016
and they stopped doing this test in july
because there's quite frankly so many
during this time period there were 1 274
islamic attacks
in which 11 774 people were killed
in 14 303 killed around the world
exactly radical islam it's all saved
together let's not say it together how
about
we take the advice of our friend and not
offend over 1.7 billion people over the
globe and pulling out these statistics
we're going to address that now how
about that succeed tony statistics out
of a rabbit hat
i mean what's the source you got to
quote the source tell us you know where
they're getting this stuff
uh how would you answer this you know
when i heard the clip i was surprised
when they quoted 11 000 people dying by
quote unquote
radical islam or muslims they have not
quoted any source
number one even if the source is true
let's look at the global picture by the
way you know i'm from chicago
in this year up until now there are 700
murders in the city of chicago just one
city
many more in detroit many more in l.a
new york so every murder every killing
of the innocent
we should condemn it every so we should
not just restrict the term terrorism
to just the acts done by a muslim
terrorism or causing terror to the
innocent people
it's been done by people of different
faiths different countries nationalities
and races
so every murder is an act of terrorism
so when we take that into account
there were 700 acts of terrorism in
chicago taking place
by chicagoans and we should all condemn
it
but why stop up there according to the
statistics
from 911 up until now means uh
december 2015 there have been 406
000 mass shootings not mass shootings uh
gun death by gun violence in the usa
that's close to half a million so each
single act of killing innocent person
again is an act of terrorism so when you
compare
11 000 compared to close to half a
million this is nothing
you know i mean obviously we as muslims
as humans we should cry out for every
single person
that is dying innocent life is being
lost
every drop of blood is sacred but when
we compare 11
000 to half a million acts of terrorism
happens in the usa we should all condemn
it
and we should not label those acts as
american terrorism
or radical usa we should just say that
each single act humans are doing it
because of emotions because of grievance
because of anger because of their mental
state
and definitely not because of the us
constitution
in the same way when we look at the acts
of killing by some muslims
a minute minority of the muslims in some
countries
it's very important that geopolitical
factors are the main reason
why they're doing it sometimes to fight
fight oppression sometimes to uh
fight the dictators which are there
taking away the rights
sometimes to uh because of anger and
vengeance and grievance because of the
drone missiles because of
uh because of the aid strikes
all of these could be the reasons but
these are not the excuses my dear
my dear friends islam says that you
cannot take innocent life
in though even though atrocities may be
done to you your family your country
even then islam does not give a right
to a muslim to kill any innocent person
so we condemn those acts the statistics
that they mention
there is no evidence to it and let's not
just pick on muslims only
we have to condemn the muslims whenever
they're doing bad things
but let's look at the global picture
that
committing of the acts is a minor
minority of percentage
compared to the acts done similar acts
in the usa
similar acts in europe similar acts in
china russia
so when we look at the global picture
people are killing each other
we have to look at the cause we have to
condemn it
and we have to we have to find ways
how we could reduce or eliminate it so
we can live in peace and harmony
as brothers and sisters with humanity
that's interesting you mentioned that
because many people they don't look at
the facts on the ground i mean and they
throw out these
these statistics didn't give a reference
there's a
study that was done by the university
of north carolina now this is a
prestigious university and they showed
that last
to get this less than 0.002 percent of
americans
killed since 9 11
were killed by muslims and i hesitate
there because muslim is one who submits
to the will of god
just like jesus was a muslim moses
abraham so anyone who's submitting to
the will of god
he can't be radical or going against
peace and the mission of peace which
what islam is promoting
so no such thing as radical muslim
radical islam the individual is crazy
and saying look islam says don't drink
alcohol
there's muslims drinking alcohol islam
says don't gamble
muslims gambling islam says don't kill
innocent men women and children some
muslims might do it don't
the whole if i don't matter if the
statistics are through the roof which
they're not
it's against islam so you can't blame
islam
you don't blame the drunk driver
you don't drain the car for the drunk
driver do you the manufacturer of the
car no you blame that driver the
individual
so like my good friend dr seville was
saying geopolitical and he's not
terrorist expert why don't you bring on
a terrorist expert
in my opinion it's injustice humiliation
oppression that is are the most common
causes
of terrorism some people claim that
religion motivates terrorists
however the academic research of dr
robert pape has proved the claim to be
false
uh what i did is i collected the first
complete database
of every suicide terrorist attack around
the world
since 1980 the first version of this
database
uh was published a few years ago and it
went from 1980 to 2003.
think of that as like the pre-iraq
database and then the second version
from
2004 on think of that as the data that's
happened since iraq um and what the data
shows quite clearly
is that uh the principal cause of
suicide terrorism is
foreign occupation in that period from
1980 to 2003
there were 315 completed
suicide terrorist attacks by 462
suicide terrorists who actually killed
themselves i don't mean attempts these
are people who
actually killed themselves the world
leader
during that 24-year period was not an
islamic group at all
there are the tamil tigers in sri lanka
the tamil tigers
are a marxist group a secular group
a hindu group in fact over half
of those 462 suicide attackers
were purely secular because you see many
muslim suicide terrorist groups are also
pure purely secular such as the pkk
in turkey the pkk in turkey which
did numerous suicide attacks in the
1990s
is again a marxist read anti-religious
suicide terrorist group because you see
if
islam as uh sort of a radical religion
or if it were just radical muslims uh
doing this then what you would expect is
sort of this thin veneer of suicide
attack
kind of scattered all around the world
uh you would expect that oh there's 1.4
billion muslims
you know there's this teeny tiny fringe
of muslims kind of everywhere who'd be
willing to do suicide attack
uh but that's not the way the data looks
it's really concentrated
and it's really concentrated in
occupations
like you know dr pape yes you know what
he said tell him what he said dr papi
about
about this fact where he talked about so
important this is a terrorist
expert please alex jones and these other
individuals bring
bring this bring experts like this who
will clearly said they analyzed over 2
000 sub plus
terrorist attacks and he said that islam
had little to nothing to do
with motivating people to do such
criminal acts
come on there is not a single passage in
the quran
there are six thousand plus passages or
ayas verses in the quran
not a single one of them incites a
person
to commit to commit acts of terrorism
in fact the passages of the quran they
are there to unite humanity
under the worship of one god they are
there to motivate people to do good to
others
they are there to prevent wars they are
there to to connect hearts
with other hearts and minds so we can
live in peace and harmony and justice
with each other
there is not a single passage from
muhammad peace be upon him
that incites a person to commit acts of
terrorism
in fact there are passages from muhammad
peace be upon him
in which he mentioned that you are not a
believer
if you eat you're full and if your
neighbors are hungry wow
you know how can a person commit acts of
terrorism when a person is supposed to
look out for the neighbors
so there are passages after passages and
examples and examples from muhammad
peace be upon him
that came to guide humanity that that
came
to make sure that we live in in peace
and harmony
under the worship of the one creator so
these are the teachings of islam
you know just like just like uh
people have abused the old testament and
the new testament
and they committed acts of atrocities
like the crusaders
some people have misused the buddhist
scriptures
and the political stance and they are
abusing and killing
innocent muslims in burma some
christians
in the dark ages they committed acts
heinous acts
atrocities against the muslims in the
inquisition
for all of these acts we don't blame
christianity we don't blame judaism
hinduism buddhism
we blame those people it is the
shortcomings of those people
in the same way when we look at the
geopolitical environment
there are many many reasons many many
causes that are
inciting a person to commit acts of
terrorism
and definitely it is not the quran it is
not islam
because islam and the quran and the
example of muhammad peace be upon him
they came to unite humanity under the
worship of the one creator
and the way that they have created the
wonderful uh
wonderful environment in the history of
islam
that how people they used to live in
peace and harmony like in muslim spain
ruling under islam the christians the
jews and the
people of other faiths that used to come
and they learn within the islamic rule
how it was the golden age in baghdad in
cairo in
damascus and in spain so these are the
examples
of the true teachings of islam if
somebody is misusing it
we blame the person we condemn the
person but not the faith
of islam brilliant removing the
ignorance before we go to the next clip
so
i had mentioned the stud the study that
was done dr
b of north carolina and they came
with the numbers of 0.002 percent
of america since 9 11. and you know you
have like 3 000 and this is what's
fascinating you know you don't have the
shows like alex jones they know that
muslims weren't responsible for that
this is what they propagate and you have
a clip of trump
we'll go to this clip great donald
you're probably the best known
builder uh particularly of of great
buildings
in the city there's a great deal of
question about
whether or not the damage and and the
ultimate destruction of the buildings
was caused
by the airplanes by architectural defect
or possibly by bombs or
or aftershocks do you have any thoughts
on that well it was an architectural
defect
the world trade center was always known
as a very very strong building don't
forget that took a big bomb in the
basement now the basement is the most
vulnerable place because that's your
foundation
and it withstood that and i got to see
that area
about three or four days after it took
place because one of my structural
engineers
actually took me for a tour because he
did the building and i said i can't
believe it the building was standing
solid
and half of the columns were blown out i
mean so this was an
unbelievably powerful building if you
know anything about structure it was one
of the first buildings that was built
from the outside the steel
the reason the world trade center had
such narrow windows is that in between
all the windows you had the steel on the
outside so you distilled the outside of
the building
that's why when i first looked and you
had big heavy i-beams
when i first looked at it i couldn't
believe it because there was a hole
in the steel and this is steel that was
you remember
the width of the windows in the world
trade center folks i think you you know
if you're ever up there they were quite
narrow and in between was this heavy
steel
i said how could a plane even a plane
even a 767 or 747
or whatever it might have been how could
it possibly go through this deal
i happen to think that they had not only
a plane but they had bombs that exploded
almost simultaneously because i just
can't imagine
anything being able to go through that
wall most buildings are built with the
steelers on the inside around the
elevator shaft
this one was built from the outside
which is the strongest structure you can
have
and it was almost just like a like a can
of soup
and they know about the 3000 plus
architects and engineers that are
questioning the official story alex
these are the people from alex jones
they bring this stuff up
brand new poll that show that more and
more americans
are rethinking what happened on 9 11 and
increasingly more people are saying they
do not believe the government's version
of events
i'm a family member trying to find out
the answers to the murder of 3 000 plus
people
please look at architects and engineers
people all around the world scientists
all around the world are questioning
this it took some kind of
consciousness raising on my part before
i was willing to
look at the possibilities and really you
need to go
where the evidence leads as an engineer
i have three degrees in engineering
i signed that petition for architects
and engineers
for 9 11 truth some time ago because the
american people
absolutely need the truth of 9 11.
look at the evidence in fact i'll say
this very categorically
any reasonable person who looks at the
evidence that's been brought forward
has got to come away with the feeling
that something
has to be done a real investigation
has to be put forward if you can watch
that video
and not have your convictions changed
regarding
how 9 11 happened then
you just kind of you need to get an eeg
you know an eeg an electrocephalogram
something to check your brain waves
i mean if you can watch that that
documentary
and walk away with the conviction
that that you came in with something's
just wrong
so you are the ones promoting like don't
believe all the hype from the mass media
but why are you guys
not working together with your brothers
and humanity and promoting this false
hubble radical is
this fake boogie man that's been created
you know according to the consumer
safety reports you have
more of a chance of being killed by your
furniture than some muslim
terrorists so come on guys you know five
father last essentially 500
out of the last 12 nobel peace prize
winners were muslims
so according to these stats you know
when you say muslim muslim should be
people who you associate with the
peacemakers because they're winning
the majority of the nobel peace prize
prizes let's go to the next clip my
friends
and he asked them what do you think
about sharia law
from children all up to old women all
like sharia law is good
and then he asked do you prefer sharia
law over american law
they all said yes iraq and afghanistan
and other muslim nations
uh it's okay to lie to non-believers so
for them when they when they
do that and they lie and they know
they're not being truthful it's okay
because at the end of the day they're
trying it's an end to a mean or mean to
an ends
so they're doing that so they can get in
i sometimes think do they actually
believe the stuff that they're
sharing the information that they're
sharing with people do they actually
do they did actually believe this do
they cover the thing about this like
creeping sharia
that they interviewed some people and
they were talking about we'd rather have
sharia and what also the other thing
that muslims are allowed to lie
and all this other hogwash how would you
respond to this
if by sharia law if they mean
killing innocent people forcefully
converting them
suppressing the minorities suppressing
the women
if this is what they mean by the sharia
law i
also condemn the sharia law or that
version of the sharia law
or that misunderstanding of the sharia
law i would never believe in that
but that's not what sharia law stands
for by the way
sharia law in plain simple english
definition
is god's guidance it's a how-to manual
that god has given to humanity
and that manual that guidance that
sharia law given to muhammad peace be
upon him
is not the only guidance given to
humanity the ten commandments
in the old testament in the book of
exodus chapter 20 verse number three the
ten commandments we say
that that was the guidance the sharia
law given to prophet moses and his
people
jesus acknowledged that in matthew
chapter
chapter 5 verse number 17 jesus jesus
peace be upon him he acknowledged
the sharia law or the guidance given in
the old testament
he said i came not to destroy the law
or the prophets i came to fulfill
anyone who takes away any small portion
of that law
is the least in the kingdom anyone who
oppose the law is the highest in the
kingdom
so sharia law is god's guidance given to
previous prophets including prophet
jesus
moses david abraham peace be upon all of
them
now very important for a muslim if you
ask do you believe in the sharia law the
muslims will say yes
because sharia law is islam shall we
allah is god's guidance
what are some of the examples right some
of you may be asking really shariah is
god's guidance we believe in that yes
jesus believed in sharia law when jesus
did not ate pork when the old testament
said do not eat pork
book of leviticus chapter 11 verse
number seven
that was the guidance the sharia law
given to prophet moses and his people
muslims we don't eat pork we are
following the sharia law given to
prophet moses
when i respect my parents take care of
my mother my parents my neighbors uh
i'm following the sharia law so yes if
somebody is going to ask me
do you follow the sharia law i would say
yes
i need i i have to be good to my
neighbors that's part of the sharia law
if i give charity to a poor person in
the downtown of chicago
i'm following the sharia law if i'm
helping assisting a person in the
hospital and following the sharia law
if i'm smiling at my brothers my sisters
in humanity
i'm following the sharia law so sharia
law is god's guidance
it came to unite humanity it came to
discipline humanity
it came to provide justice and morality
and peace to humanity any person
can take or misuse anything by the way
people have misused democracy
to commit atrocities or communism or
judaism christianity hinduism buddhism
people have misused
any concept any terminology
any terms to misuse it to commit heinous
acts all throughout history
so we should not blame that concept we
should blame the people
in the same way if anyone is misusing
sharia law
and and uh forcefully converting some
minorities
suppressing the women or beheading
innocent people
they are going against the concept the
spirit
and the teachings of the sharia law you
hear often
that false message that
islam is allowing people to it's it's
just i like i said
it's ludicrous absurd when you hear this
stuff
and i say like do they actually believe
this they talk about muslims being able
to lie
which was just ridiculous what do you
think
how would you respond to that right
right you know there are six thousand
plus passages in the quran
6 000 plus not a single passage says
that yes go and lie
just because a person is non-muslim go
and lie
there is no such passage however there
are some exceptions right there are
exceptions
suppose suppose if you hear a knock at
the door
and you look out and you see a woman
standing up there
she's all crying and hair all over the
place
and she's saying that you know these
people are after her
about to assault her and kill her and
compromise her
dignity please open the door and you
open the door and you protect her
and then after two minutes you see these
people
10 gang members out there and they
approach your house
and they ask have you seen this lady
what are you going to say are you going
to say that yes she's inside come and
get her
or are you going to say no we have not
seen her
you're lying but you're lying to protect
a life
you're not lying just because you want
to lie
you're lying to save somebody's dignity
somebody's life
so there's an exception you agree with
that i agree with that
so if you are going to say that islam is
giving this exception
and then you are painting the whole
islam is saying that islam allows lies
you are just misusing exceptions like
that
and these exceptions are rational
logical exceptions
every person every religion accepts
these exceptions
so no there is not a single passage in
the quran that says go ahead and lie
just for the sake of lying or lie to the
unbelievers just because they are
unbelievers
there is no passage in the quran and
then there is no authentic narration
about it or regarding it from prophet
muhammed peace be upon him
in that context historically when we
look at the life of prophet muhammad
peace be upon him who is described in
the quran
as the best example for all of us to
follow
in chapter 33 of the quran verse number
21.
so when we look at his life from the
time that he was born up until the time
he passed away
people used to call him by the term
or by the attribute of assad
the most truthful and the most honest
so if islam allowed lies how come there
is not a single instance
in the lifetime of muhammad peace be
upon him that either a muslim or a
non-muslim
can bear evidence that the prophet lied
if islam allowed it why didn't he lie to
the unbelievers to the jews to the
christians to the mushrikeen of the time
not a single evidence so that means if
we are supposed to follow muhammad peace
be upon him we should be like him
that means we should neither lie
nor be dishonest so that's those are the
teachings of islam so there is no truth
in that islam allows lies muhammad is
the best example peace be upon him
and he was the most truthful person as
silly as it
may sound when you hear these things
it's out there
people are propagating this
misinformation let's go to the next clip
so we can
hopefully help eradicate some of this
sincere ignorance conscience's stupidity
all in the essence hopefully we can work
together with some of these people
who are propagating this stuff if this
gets to them and now they can either
continue on
with these lies and misinformation have
truly
equals a lie or they can go ahead and
invite us bring us on and let's work
together
go ahead let's go to the next clip they
want to you know claim that they're the
peaceful
religion or the religion of peace
meanwhile to prove it they're willing to
go out and kill
people and or attack them cut them drive
them over with cars throw them off
bridges
uh kill homosexuals do all this stuff to
prove just how peaceful they are
that's insane it is insane whoa a lot of
uh information where do you start
if they are going out of their way
to show islam is a religion of peace
bringing peace into the life of so many
people who submit their will to the
creator that's what islam means to
submit your will
to almighty god you guys know as
christians
the lord's prayer or our father who art
in heaven hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come die will be done that's
what islam means
to submit your will to almighty god and
a muslim is one who has submitted to god
but now dr sabil you heard
the rhetoric that muslims are going out
of their way
to show islam is peaceful by killing
this person beheading this person
what's your response you know as muslims
as americans
as humans if any person does any heinous
acts
the way that that person did we have to
condemn it we just plain black and white
but we cannot attach the faith of islam
to that act
or the faith of christianity for that
matter
you know there is no there is no excuse
for what he did
so all i need to say again is that when
you look at the passages from quran
and the example from prophet muhammad
peace be upon him
those passages they incite people to
unite with other humans to be good to
other people to
be good to neighbors there is not a
single passage that incites a person
to commit acts of atrocities a person
can take anything out of context
as people have done to christianity
judaism hinduism buddhism
but we don't blame those faiths we blame
the person
you know when the question came or the
allegation came that uh
you know these people is in minnesota
from the sudanese background they want
to live under the sharia law in sudan
somehow it gives the impression that
people want to impose the sharia law in
the usa by force
and what not that's not the case because
as muslims as americans because we are
americans by the way yes
we believe in islam but we are also
americans
when we look at a very important
statistic
it shows that 57 of the republicans
in this country when they took the
survey last year
57 percent of republicans they said that
they want to replace the u.s
constitution
with christianity so are we not going to
say
you know radical christianity the
radical republicans the radical
christians are
have a conspiracy they want to take over
and they want to
overrule the constitution are we going
to uh
you know go in that direction perhaps
not
so in the same way those muslims who
mention they want to rule by the sharia
law
you have to look at the definition of
the sharia law that they give
if the definition is that suppressing
women
atrocities converting force conversions
obviously no one would like that
that's not sharia law sharia law came
to oppose that to fight discrimination
sharia law came to give rights to the
minorities
of freedoms to the people of other
faiths
and unity to humanity so it's very
important for our viewers
especially mr alex jones and his anchor
people
that please read on islam read the
passages from the quran in context
let's not use double standard to blame
islam for the acts of a few minority of
the muslims
just like we don't want to blame
christianity for the acts
of a few minority of the christians the
good and bad apples and all over the
place
if you want to know what islam is pick
up the quran
we could send it to you for free if you
call 800
662 islam we'll send you a free english
translation of the quran
read it in context if you have any
questions give us a call
we'll be happy to discuss that with you
and in closing
in closing this summarizes what islam
says
there's a passage in the quran chapter
49 of the quran verse number 13
1 3 god is speaking to humanity and god
is saying
that o mankind o humanity i
means god has created you from one
single male and one single female
and made you into peoples and tribes
that you get to know each other that you
get to know each other
not that you may despise each other
and the best amongst you is the one who
is a well-mannered person
so this is what islam teaches it it came
to bring humanity together as brothers
and sisters
worshiping the one creator and forming
societies
which are going to be based upon
morality based upon
justice based upon equality and yes
the outcome of all of this would be
peace
so we hope and pray that you learn more
about islam
let's work together so we can have the
best world for all of us
and the best hereafter but by god's
guidance and mercy
in the hereafter and thank you for
everybody who tuned in
we try to clear up these false notions
and these misconceptions
and hopefully if you've had an open
heart and open mind you can
put things together and see that the way
things have been presented to you
have troops as i said equals one lie a
big lie
the program alex jones show has been
known to expose some of the lies that
are out there
but now you jump on the bandwagon you
start bashing islam and muslims
and not bringing on muslims to go ahead
and represent their
faith i mean you're not contributing to
better humanity
you're actually causing harm to humanity
you don't want to do that
we started off also with martin luther
king talked about the greatest danger to
mankind is sincere ignorance if i want
if you want to learn karate go to a
karate expert you want to learn jujitsu
come to me
you want to learn about the muslims come
to the muslim invite the muslim
we invite you formally to come on our
program
come on let's have a healthy dialogue
get to the bottom of things
let us come on your program let's talk
about it
and hopefully we can work together
instead of
feeding into this fear frenzy and and
this these lies and misinformation
and and at the end you're not
contributing to making
society the world a better place
you're just promoting fear anxiety
and misinformation i know you guys don't
want to do that do you you want to
continue doing that
no you don't so come on let's let's work
together
uh we'll see you next time every week
here on the dean show until then peace
be with you salami